wann und woher gab es erste Hinweise
Infos über dieses
Auschwitz vom fleetwist mittlerweile
heißt aus aiwang aus diesem aus dem
alberner Umfeld wann gab es die ersten
Hinweise ich glaube man muss wissen dass
es Gerüchte über eine rechte Gesinnung
in Jugendjahren über Hubert Aiwanger
schon sehr lange gibt das begleitet ihn
eigentlich seit einer bayerischen
Landespolitik angekommen ist 2008 also
im Landtag eingezogen ist und der erste
ganz konkrete Hinweis auf dieses
Pamphlet hat die Kollegen aus dem Bayern
Teil der szte diese Recherche betrieben
haben Anfang August erreicht wenn sie
sagen erste Hinweise oder Hinweise auf
eine frühere rechte Gesinnung gab schon
länger woher kam die
die Klassenkameraden die Altersgenossen
von Ellwanger haben erzählt in dem
überschaubaren Ort das Thema kommt ja
mal lassendorf in Niederbayern dass das
so war und das hat sie natürlich dann
irgendwann auch bis nach München rum
gesprochen aber es ließ sich nie
erhärten und jetzt gab es eben zu
Hinweis tatsächlich mal das Flugblatt
dinglich dazu und das war für die
Kollegen der Anstoß aus dem diese
Recherche erwachsen ist mit dem schweren
Verdacht dass ich jetzt aber erhärtet
woher kam dieses Flugblatt jetzt also
das kann man sagen das war ein
ehemaliger Lehrer von Hubert Aiwanger
der damals
disziplinarisch mit diesem Fall befasst
war Hubert Albaner wurde an seinem
Gymnasium für den Besitz dieses
Flugplatz bestraft der hat ein Referat
erhalten müssen und dieser Lehrer und
andere Lehrer haben das bestätigt dass
es so wichtig für den Besitz also das
heißt es wurde in seinem Schultornister
gefunden oder oder im Schulranzen
gefunden er wurde gefunden
mehrere Exemplare gefunden die genaue
Zahl weiß man auch nicht aber
die Möglichkeit dass das geschrieben hat
wurde von den Lehrern und an der Schule
als war angenommen und jetzt sind damals
davon ausge sagen das erst geschrieben
hat dafür bestraft worden und er hat
jetzt konfrontiert nach erscheinender
Recherche der Süddeutschen Zeitung
gesagt dass er nicht er es war sondern
oder sein Bruder helmut hat sich
gemeldet und hat Verantwortung
übernommen
die Süddeutsche Zeitung hatte ein
Gutachten des bewiesen hat dass die
Schreibmaschine auf der dieses Pamphlet
geschrieben wurde die gleiche war auf
der hubert-eiwanger seine Facharbeit für
die Schule fürs Gymnasium geschrieben
hat damit und erst danach kam Hubert
aibank mit der Theorie sein Bruder
könnte das gemacht haben das muss einen
kann einen stutzig machen muss natürlich
nicht
der hat möglicherweise auch auf dieser
Schreibmaschine geschrieben das kann man
natürlich nicht ausschließen
also tatsächlich ernst gemeint jetzt
also ne kann ja sein also man kann es
nicht zu Hause
geschrieben
bekannt ist das ist ja sehr viel
passiert seit der ersten Aufschlag der
Set am letzten Freitag Abend erschienen
ist inzwischen hat also selber zugegeben
dass
indirekt formuliert hat gesagt in
Erwachsenen Jahren war da kein Antisemit
liegt nahe dass eine Vergangenheit in
Jugendjahren haben könnte wo es war
nachdem Alter weiß wird doch
wahrscheinlicher dass er der Auto das
ist komplett schwarz ansprechen ja er
hat sich heute dazu geäußert und wir
hören einmal kurz rein
was für eine Aussage
ja man fragt sich wer für in die
Krisenkommunikation macht also das
scheint mir nicht jemand zu sein der das
Handwerk versteht
das jemand sehr angefasst ne da ist sehr
angefasst aber er macht es natürlich mit
jedem Tag schlimmer und das ist insofern
ich würde mal sagen unabhängig jetzt
davon ob
man ihn jetzt nachweisen kann was ja
rechtlich übrigens durchaus relevant ist
ob man die nachweisen kann dass es
tatsächlich selber war oder nicht war
und und die Regeln der Verdacht
Berichterstattung und so weiter die alle
wichtig sind ist es so dass wenn man
jetzt anschaut was passiert ist seit die
Veröffentlichung auf dem Markt das muss
man sagen also hätte man von jemandem
erwartet der von sich sagt er sei
Demokrat und so weiter dass er sich
nicht nur klar distanziert sondern auch
irgendeine Erklärung dafür liefert die
nicht sozusagen derart fragmentarisch
und unglaubwürdig ist wie er das jetzt
getan hat also ich meine die der Einwand
sein Bruder habe das geschrieben weil er
sich über die Schule geärgert habe das
ist einfach also ich das ist einfach
nicht lebensnah ja dass jemand sowas
schreibt irgendwie
ausschnittsvergnügungspark bezeichnet um
sich von den Lehrern abzugrenzen die
dann sozusagen sehr allgemein irgendwie
alle als linksradikal also irgendwie
bezeichnet werden
die ganze der ganze Duktus dieses
Pamphlet erinnert ja sehr stark an den
Humor den man in nazikreisen beobachten
kann ich habe sofort gedacht an dieses
pogrom-lied das war das NSU
wie heißt das Monopoly Spiel das
entwickelt wurde wo auch ganz ähnliche
Witze in Anführungszeichen gemacht
wurden über über KZ und ähnliches wer da
reinkommt unter welchen Umständen also
das und dazu muss man irgendeine Haltung
einnehmen und natürlich spielt es eine
Rolle das 35 Jahre vergangen sind und
ich würde nicht unbedingt sagen dass
eine ganz klare Linie führt von dem
damaligen 17-Jährigen zu den heutigen
Aussagen oder der in Erding ge geöffnet
hat aber man würde es zumindest von
jemandem der derartige Verantwortung
trägt in seinem Bundesland und auch
weiterhin tragen will erwarten dass er
das irgendwie erklärt und das hat er
nicht getan und jetzt kommen wir hören
wir heute dass er dass das eine oder
andere so oder so interpretiert werden
kann wo ich sage nein tut mir leid so
ein Pamphlet kann nicht so oder so
interpretiert werden und das hat er
versäumt und da hat er das ist ja
sozusagen der alte Fehler ja am Ende
stolpert man gar nicht über das was
passiert ist sondern über den schlechten
Umgang damit und das ist also ein langer
paradigmatisch gezeigt wie schauen Sie
darauf
der ich glaube dass die Stimmung in der
CSU zurzeit sehr schlecht ist weil bis
der Wahlkampf hat in Bayern plötzlich
ein Thema bekommen und die CSU steht vor
einer Frage
lässt sie ihn fallen auf die Gefahren
dass das
solidarisierungseffekte in dem Milieus
auslöst und er ist nach der Wahl wieder
da oder vielleicht Stellplatz
also es ist plötzlich ist Herrn Söder
die geplante Wahlkampfkampagne
entglitten
das Themen Setting er ist gerne Fleisch
er nimmt an jedem Volksfest Teil die
Grünen sind böse all dieses da redet
kaum noch jemand drüber und er wird
ständig befragt dazu ich glaube das ist
aus Sicht der CSU das weswegen die
zurzeit auf die Freien Wähler nicht gut
zu sprechen das war aber nicht die Frage
die
ich würde sowas ganz ungeheuerliches tun
wollen ich würde den Fokus weglenken
wollen von der CSU mal schauen immer auf
die Seelen auf den Jungs und den Damen
muss man auf die Finger schauen aber die
Freien Wähler sind jetzt in der
Verantwortung die lassen sich gerade von
Hubert Aiwanger einen Art Geiselhaft
nehmen haben sich jetzt entschieden
dieses Thema das wirklich so sensibel
ist Antisemitismus der Kernbestand
unseres demokratischen Konsenses dieses
Thema zum Wahlkampfthema zu machen zur
Abstimmung drüber ob man das stehen
lassen kann oder nicht und das ist ein
Schritt der die Gesellschaft spalten
kann
von Söder und das nur einmal kurz
abzuschließen ist ja von Herrn richtig
beschrieben und ich glaube es wird noch
mal verstärkt durch die Tatsache dass er
sich ja auch von Friedrich Merz als der
über die Frage der kommunalen
Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD z.B
nachdachte sehr sehr klar abgegrenzt hat
und sagte das gibt's auf gar keiner
Ebene keinerlei Zusammenarbeit mit
Menschen die irgendwie rechtsradikal
rechtsextrem was auch immer sind
wenn jetzt plötzlich so ein Verdacht im
Raum steht hast du politisch natürlich
ein gigantisches Problem Klarheit war
nie die größte Stärke von Markus Söder
aber in zwei Fragen war da immer klar
Antisemitismus genau und seit seiner
seit seinem
selbstverschuldeten Wahlkampf Crash 2018
auch bei der Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD
das muss man Markus Söder wirklich
lassen deswegen sage ich Freien Wähler
die die Minister oder Fraktionschef
Streibl der Freien Wähler die lassen
Hubert einfach nur gewähren obwohl er
als stellvertretende Ministerpräsident
ja auch unser Gemeinwesen die Werte des
Landes verkörpern sollte und eigentlich
müssten die Freien Wähler ihren Chef
dazu zwingen oder ihn dazu zu bewegen
dass er transparent aufdeckt was war
dass er das reflektiert und dass er
glaubhaft macht dass er diese
Vergangenheit bewältigt hat und solange
das nicht geschieht kann Huber
eigentlich nicht in so einer
herausgehobenen Funktionen in einem
Staatsamt verbleiben die Freien Wähler
sind tatsächlich am Zug da ist die
Integrität einzelner spitzenfiguren
jetzt in Frage
die Geschichte dieses pamphlets erzählen
was ist der Hintergrund in welchem
Kontext musst du das verstehen und wie
alt war Hubert alwanger als dieses Ding
entstanden ist 17 da würde ich jetzt
dazu sagen einem 17-Jährigen gegenüber
sollte man zum milde fähig sein aber der
52-Jährige der in so einem hohen Amt ist
den muss man streng betrachten und
Hubert albern könnte also wer hätte wenn
er auf die Anfragen der sz-kollegen drei
Anfragen vor Veröffentlichung wenn er da
ehrlich geantwortet hätte wenn er gesagt
hätte nehmen wir an der Bruder war es
wirklich halte für sehr unwahrscheinlich
aber kann wenn er das auf eine dieser
Anfragen geantwortet hätte dann wäre
dieser Artikel wahrscheinlich nicht
erschienen weil der Bruder Privatmann
ist wenn er das glaubhaft gemacht hätte
und keine Person des öffentlichen Lebens
wie Huber er hat auf konkrete Fragen
oder im Besitz des Flugplatz war was
verteilt hat hatte die Vorwürfe
zurückgewiesen er hatte SZ ganz klein
wenig zugespitzt angelogen und erst
unter höchsten Druck hatte die
Geschichte mit dem Bruder präsentiert
und zu dem Flugblatt muss man wissen das
Flugblatt ist tatsächlich das liest sich
nicht wie Eruption eines Schülers der
durchgefallen ist ja das wäre die Bruder
Theorie sondern das atmet einen
antisemitischen des atmet einen Nazi
verehrenden Geist es ist durch
komponiert es ist die Parodie auf einen
Wettbewerb das damaligen
Bundespräsidenten zur zu deutschen
Vergangenheitsbewältigung und das war
also gezielte Bestattung
Verächtlichmachung von
[Musik]
den Versuch sich der deutschen
Geschichte zu stellen und der Jargon der
da verwandt wird ist so schwerwiegend
dass man auch 35 Jahre später nicht
drüber weggehen kann wenn das gut
erklären würde und die Chance wird immer
kleiner weil er hat es mehrmals verpasst
dann könnte man sowas durchaus verzeihen
aber wenn das so im Raum steht ohne dass
es eingeordnet wird ohne dass man das
Gefühl hat er bereut es ist es schwierig
ich habe den Eindruck Hubert Aiwanger
ist momentan nicht der Vorgang damals
unangenehm sondern die Probleme die
heute daraus für ihn erwachsen ich meine
nach vier Tagen hat er einmal getwittert
und hat getwittert Schmutzkampagne also
eine einzige Reaktion in den sozialen
Medien war ein sz-bashing und sich nicht
Verhalten zu den Vorwürfen das ist kein
verantwortungsvoller Umgang also nur als
Ergänzung was interessantes auch hier
erlebt war nicht vor allzu langer Zeit
hier in der Sendung Hubert einfacher
damit über die diesen Demokratie Satz
der in Erding gefallen ist gesprochen
und mir ist eine sozusagen eine
rhetorische Taktik Technik aufgefallen
die man von Donald Trump kennt also wenn
du angegriffen wirst dann sagst du
sofort alles Lüge war ich nicht und
behauptet einfach irgendetwas anderes
aber du gibst niemals irgendetwas zu
du stehst auch niemals irgendetwas ein
Gegner an character assassination wie
man das drüben nennt ja genau und das
beendet Trump immer schon an es färbt ab
andere Politiker ja in den letzten
Jahren immer stärker in USA und das ist
auch in Europa in ich glaube wir sehen
es in Ungarn in Polen in anderen
europäischen Ländern wo wir einen Umgang
mit
brisanten Themen haben die im Grunde
normalisiert werden
absolut okay sowas zu sagen oder so ein
paar Plätze zu schreiben genau und das
Interessante ist ist sozusagen Teil 2
der Frage an Roman Deininger das ist in
dem Fall nicht passiert
in dem Fall war die Taktik erstmal
nichts zu sagen nichts zu sehr
abzublocken und dann so scheibchenweise
irgendwie zu reagieren Hubert einwanger
hat seine Glaubwürdigkeit durch seine
Reaktion Stück für Stück beschädigt und
ich sage zum Beispiel dazu dass ich
Hubert Aiwanger mag ich fand der war
lange so auch wirklich so süffige
Geschichten und Stücke über ihn
geschrieben und es gibt ein Einsatz dann
habe ich noch genau im Kopf von einem
Stück das Roman Dallinger geschrieben
hat über Hubert Aiwanger und da sagen
sie so sinngemäß man fragt sich immer
war das jetzt der eine der Satz zu viel
war das das eine Ding zu viel und
beschreiben dann wie er es schafft immer
wieder trotzdem gegen alle
Wahrscheinlichkeit zurückzukommen und
sogar stärker als zuvor leider geschafft
hat eben weil er so als seltsames Wesen
aus den Wäldern des Süden wahrgenommen
wird
dass er die Maßstäbe die für ihn gelten
so gedehnt hat dass er mit allem davon
kommt und das versuchte ging es wieder
Hubert aibanker ist niemand der die
Flinte ins Korn schmeißt
der wirkt entschlossen das durchzuziehen
aber das durchziehen ist eine
Belastungsprobe für die politische
Kultur in Bayern ich würde sogar sagen
in Deutschland dass die Freien Wähler
des mitmachen ist schwierig und dass die
Lämmer von Markus Söder das hört ihn
gerade schon angesprochen hat ist
tatsächlich meine Wahrnehmung ist in der
CSU glaubt Huber Leihwagen diese
Erklärung niemand mit dem Bruder aber es
ist ja auch gar nicht so entscheidend es
ist klar das stellvertretenden
Ministerpräsident des Freistaats Bayern
hat rechtsextremistische Haltung gehabt
in seinen Jugendjahren das schält sich
jetzt heraus
sagen und Zeugenaussagen die jetzt quasi
auch noch andere Medien recherchieren so
und wenn man wenn man diese Fakten auf
dem Tisch hat ja dann sollte man
eigentlich meinen ähm die Leute draußen
in Bayern würden verstehen dass der Mann
vielleicht nicht stellvertretender
Ministerpräsident bleiben kann aber es
gibt einfach viele Einwohner Fans es
gibt viele Leute muss ich mit ihm
solidarisieren die sagen vor 35 Jahren
das ist doch lange her und diese
Menschen muss zu wieder ernst nehmen
denn sonst treibt man viele in die in
die System Skepsis hinein deswegen musst
du da warten bis eine Entlassung
im ordentlichen Verfahren und
nachvollziehbar ist genau man muss
wirklich Belege haben ich gerade so
gestutzt als sie sagten ich mag Hubert
alwanger ich habe ihn hier erlebt und
ich habe das glaube ich habe kürzlich in
der Sendung gesagt das ist jemand für
den ich von dem ich sicher sagen würde
dass er kein rechtsextremeister ist also
und und kein keine komischen braunen
Flecken irgendwo hat nicht in seinem
jetzigen Politiker das ist mir und ist
auch den Kollegen die Recherche zunächst
gemacht haben wichtig die helene
popowski hat gerade schön gesagt heute
ist einfach nicht mit antisemitischen
Ausfällen aufgefallen aber er ist halt
doch der eine exponierte Politiker heute
in Deutschland in Parteien der Mitte was
die Freien Wähler sind die gerade im
kommunalen wirklich eine sehr
konstruktive Kraft in vielen Ecken
Deutschlands der eine Politiker der
rechtspopulistische Grenzregionen in
seiner Rhetorik erkundet und oft auch
auf der anderen Seite der Grenze
rauskommt und deswegen darf man schon
fragen war eine potenziell
demokratiefeindliche Haltung schon in
jungen Jahren angelegt die Frage darf
man stellen und dann gilt es das
17-jährige verdient milde
52-Jährige muss sich erklären und das
hat einfach nicht ausreichend getan also
die Chance dazu
2008 sieht er in den Landtag ein
erstmals
und offenbar ist ihm ja da schon klar
dass da eine politische Bombe schlummert
sehr interessant was macht der 2008 also
eine Landtag eins Hubert aiwang hat die
Freien Wähler das muss man wissen um das
immense Selbstbewusstsein dieses Mannes
zu verstehen der hat die auf seinen
Schultern in den Landtag getragen der
ist mit seinem Auto allein durch Bayern
gefahren hat plakatiert der hat die
Freien Wähler die ja gar nicht in die
Landespolitik wollten die meisten
wollten eine kommunale Kraft bleiben die
hat er mit seinem eigenen Ehrgeiz ja hat
er die in den Landtag geführt und
seitdem Weise dass er ja kleine bis
mittlere Wunder vollbringen kann und es
gibt immer immense Selbstbewusstsein und
es gibt immer jetzt das
Selbstbewusstsein die diese Sache
vielleicht doch noch gegen jede
Wahrscheinlichkeit und gegen jede
sachliche
sachliche Grundlage durchstehen zu
können einfacher hat die CSU vor sich
hergetrieben seither in der Regierung
ist mit der CSU funktioniert das
natürlich immer so gut ähm glaube er hat
es wieder du hast genervt aber für Söder
ist einfach natürlich immer ein maximal
Komode der Partner gewesen bürgerlicher
Blick auf die Welt ähnliche Welt
anschauen grünes Caps ist ausgeprägt
warum soll sich Söder Ampel Abhängigkeit
mit den Grünen in den Koalitionen kann
man aus Söder sich durchaus verstehen
aber jetzt könnte dazu gezwungen sein
das ist 2008 schickt ja jemanden vor
eine eine Kollegin von den Freien Wähler
die bei dem Lehrer das ist weil die
Begebenheit auf die ich gerade
angespielt habe schickt davor zu diesem
genannten Lehrer die Kollegen was zu
erreichen Kollegen ist Bayern teils und
recherchiert dass eine Vertraute von
Aiwanger bei dem Lehrer der quasi im
Besitz dieses Flugplatz war sich
erkundigt habe ob dem Hubert Gefahr
Truhe und natürlich kann man
vor 15 Jahren vor 15 Jahren und jetzt
wieder als diese Recherche begonnen hat
nicht nur von SZ das war noch andere
Medien
beteiligt die Kollegen haben das dann
als erste hart gekriegt
zeigt natürlich das einfacher wusste
dass da was kommen kann das hatte
bestimmt verfolgt und diese Zeitbombe 35
Jahre alt hat ihn jetzt eingeholt aber
sich offenbar nicht drauf vorbereitet
ja also in der Krisenstrategie
wahrscheinlich einfach in Sicherheit
gewogen weil er mit allem durchgekommen
ist man kann immer sagen hätte doch 35
Jahre Zeit gehabt aber wahrscheinlich
nicht damit gerechnet dass das passiert
hätte er auf die sz-anfragen wie gesagt
antworten können und hätte sich da jede
Menge Ärger erspart wenn er gesagt hätte
er schämt sich für diese Vergangenheit
und inzwischen wissen wir dass es diese
Vergangenheit in irgendeiner Form
rechtsextreme Umtriebe gab wenn er
gesagt ich schäme mich dafür ich habe
das hinter mir gelassen ich stehe mit
dieser Staatsregierung dafür dass
Antisemitismus keinen Platz hat in
Bayern und in Deutschland dann hätte er
das durchstehen können das hat er nicht
gemacht und er hat auch heute in diesem
kuriosen Fernsehen Interview wieder
unterlassen
darüber muss auch gleich noch mal reden
gibt einen ähm Zeugen der sich jetzt
sofort gemeldet hat glaube bei den
Kollegen von Report München Mario Bauer
wir hören einmal kurz rein
wenn klassische und drin war rein kam
oder gezeigt er hat auch sehr oft so
eben diese Hitler Ansprachen nachgemacht
in diesem Hitler und äh
da wollte er immer damit aufhören ja es
waren feindliche Witze und so weiter die
die sind definitiv geworden
so wie er selber heute darauf reagiert
hat sich eingelassen hat und sagt da
kann man das ein oder andere so oder so
interpretieren ist das eigentlich der
Hinweis darauf dass da noch was kommt
einfacher hat er sogar heute auf die
Frage ob da noch was komme sowas im Sinn
von schauen wir mal gesagt also er weiß
natürlich dass da mehr war und das das
meine ich mit dem Unterlassen von die
Dinge einfach einmal umfassend auf den
Tisch legen das hat jetzt wieder nicht
gemacht er hat er von Söder diesen 25
Fragenkatalog aufgetragen bekommen was
tippe ich mal ja viel um Details gegen
hat er sich hat er hatte dies und jenes
getan in Schulzeiten eigentlich haben
sie diese 25 Fragen komplett erledigt
weil er das heute schon ähm eingestanden
hat dass da was war
und zugleich hört man aus der CSU ist es
halt einfach extrem wichtig dass einfach
nur die Fähre Chance hat sich zu
erklären aber schon langsam muss man
sagen auch die die erste Chance das
Fenster schließt sich irgendwann und
dann dieser Satz seit dem
Erwachsenenalter bin ich kein Antisemit
weil es dann ein politisch tödlicher
Satz es sind politisch tödlicher Satz
und das zeigt finde ich auch dass man
ich habe ja vorhin von
Krisenkommunikation gesprochen
vielleicht hat er tatsächlich keinen
Berater aber selbst wenn er einen hätte
also in angespannten Situationen kann
man beobachten dass dann die Menschen
eben doch irgendwie in irgendeiner Weise
rauskommt was wie sie ticken ja so man
kann sich gar nicht so coachen lassen
oder man völlig versteinert und das
passt überhaupt nicht zu einfacher das
heißt ich finde man merkt in den
vergangenen Tagen dass er keine Haltung
dazu gefunden hat ja das hat sich zu
diesen Vorwürfen dass er keine
plausible Erklärung liefern kann dass er
dass er
dass er das einfach und das macht den
auch das stellt natürlich auch seine
Eignung in Frage ja einfach so jemand
der der nicht nicht das
Verantwortungsgefühl hat worum es hier
eigentlich geht ja das ist das Gute
Stichwort weil er beginnt immer seinen
Klientel dieses Bewusstsein dass man als
stellvertretender Ministerpräsident für
das ganze da sein muss für die ganze
Gesellschaft für das Gemeinwesen und
seine Werte das fehlt Hubert einfacher
weil er sich selber in dieser
einzelkämpferolle für den gesunden
Menschenverstand für die einfachen Leute
sieht die übrigens auch also diese
Gruppe die einfachen repräsentiert diese
riesengroß die darf man nicht ähm
vernachlässigen ich finde also manche
schneller
die stehen hinter ihm manche schnelle
entlassungsforderungen jetzt an Söder
von der bayerischen Opposition
berücksichtigt auch nicht genug dass man
die Reaktion dieser Menschen da
einpreisen muss man kann den nicht
rausschmeißen weil wir das in der
politischen Hygiene für Unmöglichkeiten
was einfacher wahrscheinlich gemacht hat
sondern man muss sehen dass die Menschen
draußen verstehen müssen warum das
geschieht und das ist nicht leichtfertig
geschieht und das ist auch ein gutes
Stichwort Söder dafür leichtfertigt das
war für die für die sz-kollegen
natürlich auch ein großer Schritt zu
sagen wir gehen raus mit der Geschichte
das haben die sich nicht leicht gemacht
aber sie waren überzeugt davon dass die
Geschichte stimmt weil eine Vielzahl
glaubwürdiger Zeugen das so bestätigt
hat weil auch Menschen berücksichtigt
waren die von früher kennen dies anders
gesehen haben die aber in der Minderzahl
waren und man hat ja Journalist irgendwo
auch Verantwortung auch wenn es ein
bisschen pathetisch klingt für das große
Ganze es gibt der Wächter Funktion und
stellen sie mir vor wir hätten die
Geschichte nach der Wahl gemacht ähm
jetzt kommt davor wir hätten es vor der
Wahl gemacht es gibt keinen richtigen
Zeitpunkt nur den wenn die Geschichte
fertig darüber gleich noch ein Satz
sprechen die Frage sozusagen was man als
Jugendsünde abtun kann ja und ob es dann
okay ist jemanden wie sie sagen dann
auch mit 52 dann dafür zur Rechenschaft
zu ziehen journalistisch meine ich jetzt
oder politisch tauchten weiterer Vorwurf
auf die auch in der Kollegen von Bild zu
ziehen das auch von heute die ähm der
wird eine Mitschülerin zitiert die sagt
einfacher habe mein Kampf in seinem
Schulranzen mit sich rumgeschleppt und
sie hätte es selber in der Hand gehalten
also es ist einfach die die Summe dieser
kleinen Dinge ja also mein Kampf Hitler
reden
andere Äußerungen Provokationen
natürlich kann man kann man immer sagen
naja einmal das ist vielleicht passiert
und ein zweites Mal ist es auch passiert
aber wenn man das in dieser geballt bei
der Recherche hört was die Kollegen eben
gehört haben dann kann man das nicht
ignorieren das heißt nicht dass einfach
damit restlos überführt ist oder so aber
es ist zumindest also substanzieller
Vorwurf dass er ihn ausräumen muss und
das immer wieder an dem Punkt das
Ausräumen seine Versuche das ausräumens
haben sie nicht besser gemacht sondern
nur schlimmer
gab es war interessant direkt am Anfang
schon aber auch dieser Tage hier drüber
gesprochen gab es auch direkt die Kritik
an der zZ
warum machen die das jetzt der passte
ihn nicht greifen in den Wahlkampf ein
komischer Zufall dass das jetzt gerade
so kurz vor der bayerischen Landtagswahl
kommt und so weiter die ausufernde
Verdachtsberichterstattung von der war
da plötzlich die Rede ein weiteres
Beispiel dafür dass das jetzt passiert
andere haben argumentiert und sagten
naja gut da reden wir über den
17-Jährigen Schule ist ein besonders
geschützt der Raum auch juristisch
geschützter Raum sozusagen was in
Schulen passiert hat eigentlich nichts
in der Öffentlichkeit zu suchen so kann
man auch argumentieren und so weiter
weiß auch die Kollegen vom Spiegel waren
auch an dieser Geschichte dran die hat
noch Kenntnis von dieser Geschichte und
haben sich dagegen entschieden es zu
machen
warum haben sie es gemacht also
Verdachtsberichterstattung wäre die
Macht der muss mit Kritik klarkommen die
das tun wir
wer
Verdachtsberichterstattung macht der der
weiß dass es besser ist wenn sich der
Verdacht irgendwann erhärtet aber das
ist der Fall es würde doch heute niemand
mehr sagen wenige Tage nach Erscheinen
der ersten Geschichte dass es besser
gewesen wäre wenn die Süddeutsche
Zeitung diese Geschichte nicht gemacht
hätte weil der Kern der Geschichte
einfach richtig ist und sich als
inzwischen als belegbar rausgestellt hat
es bleibt die Frage wer das Flugblatt
verfasst hat
auch nie gesagt er war was sondern wir
haben den Verdacht natürlich entscheiden
also ich glaube dass ein
stellvertretender Ministerpräsident der
Hitler Reden geschwungen hat und
Auschwitz bisschen gemacht hat was
inzwischen Leute alleine statt
versichern oder mit ihrem Namen und
Gesicht im Fernsehen dass der sich
diesen Fragen stellen muss also allein
das genügt
damit man Hubert Aiwanger dazu drängen
muss sich zu erklären und
dann ist es natürlich auch so wenn die
Kollegen nicht wirklich restlos von der
Richtigkeit in der Geschichte überzeugt
gewesen wären hätte es sie nicht gegeben
haben sie diese eidesstattlichen
Versicherungen weil sie ja viele Leute
die Entscheidung nicht mit Namen nennen
nein also erstens die Tatsache dass
viele Leute dann nicht mit Namen genannt
werden er ist der Tatsache geschuldet
dass die von sich selber sagen dass sie
in Niederbayern
gesellschaftlichen präposalien
ausgesetzt sein könnten das wollen Sie
vermeiden die Lehrer fürchten auch
dienstrechtliche negative Konsequenzen
deswegen hat sich derzeit dazu
Quellenschutz entschieden
Verdachtsberichterstattung heißt das ist
keine eidesstattlichen Erklärungen gibt
aber eine solche Vielzahl an
glaubwürdigen Zeugen die von Dingen
berichten diese selber mit eigenen Augen
gesehen haben nicht braunen nicht
Mutmaßungen sondern Dinge die sie bei
Hubert Aiwanger damals bei einem
Mitschüler gesehen haben dann die
Schwere des Vorwurfs also dieses
wirklich unappetitliche Flugblatt und
dann als weiteres Element tatsächlich
die Tatsache dass Huber heute mit
rechtspopulistischen Tönen auffällt
stellvertretender Ministerpräsident des
Freistaats Bayern da haben die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ein Recht zu
hören
von ihm wie er sich das erklärt und wenn
ich das nur anfügen darf wir sind
teilweise gefragt worden von von
Menschen die diese Recherche nicht
trauen ob den Markus Söder das ein
Auftrag gegeben hätte um sich das
unliebsamen Koalitionspartner zu
entledigen deshalb ist zum Beispiel für
völlig absurd weil wir am Ende nicht
profitieren wird von dieser Geschichte
ist die CSU also Markus Söder können
sich was anderes vorstellen als Wähler
an die AFD oder an die Freien Wähler
erklären
den Grünen in der Koalition das ist
nicht sein Wunschtraum und das Timing
sage einfach mal dazu der Hinweis kam am
Anfang August die Recherche lief und als
Recherche fertig war wurde sie
veröffentlicht das war professionelles
Vorgehen nach besten Wissen und Gewissen
wie Journalisten tun sollten es gibt ein
schönes Wort von Bob budwarz dem großen
amerikanischen Aufdecker der gesagt hat
es geht immer um die beste erhältliche
Version der Wahrheit und die haben auch
hier geliefert worden
die NZZ hat sich auch angegriffen sagte
sie verwechseln sozusagen Journalismus
mit Aktivismus und so weiter natürlich
einräumen und das tue ich jetzt hier
obwohl ich an der ursprungsrecherche
nicht beteiligt war in allerdemut
natürlich macht man Fehler natürlich
hätte man manches besser machen können
als still Kritik immer gerne an aber die
Recherche der Kollegen war im Kern
solide und hat sich jetzt als solide
bewiesen und ich glaube für die
politische in Bayern was sehr richtig
damit nach draußen zu gehen das war
eigentlich der Beweis dass Medien
unabhängig von der Staatsregierung
arbeiten würde ich sagen ich habe viele
Leser die sich melden und fragen ob
Söder morgens den Tagesbefehl rausgibt
also die Skepsis das Medien und der
Staat
die Politik unter einer Decke stecken
die ist ausgeprägt die bedient Hubert
einwange
mit Raunen statt Fakten und jetzt sind
wir wieder an der Stelle wo die Freien
Wähler gefordert sind sich für eine
sachliche Bewertung zu entscheiden und
nicht für Raunen ja und trotzdem noch
mal die Frage nach der nach der nach der
Jugendsünde sozusagen ist es zu
hartretieren die einen Politiker der
heute in Anton führen ist von dem wir
gerade festgestellt haben dass wir alle
sehr davon ausgehen dass er zwar
manchmal sehr populistisch redet aber
dennoch mit mit beiden Beinen fest in
der Mitte dieser Gesellschaft verankert
ist
in der Demokratischen Mitte dieser
Gesellschaft verankert ist sozusagen an
seinen Jugendsünden zu bemessen ich bin
da sehr bei dass man mit dem 17-Jährigen
nachsichtig umgehen muss wenn der
52-Jährige damit verantwortlich und
erwachsen umgeht und genau das ist ja
nicht hat er in die Stadt gefunden ich
würde auch sagen selbstverständlich
gehören die Freien Wähler nicht in die
rechtsrate die Partei nicht in die
rechtsradikale Ecke aber das was er in
Erding gemacht hat das ist ein klassisch
rechter
antidemokratischer Topoi gewesen wir wir
holen die Mehrheit holt sich die
Demokratie zurück das heißt eine
imaginierte eine imaginierte Mehrheit
hebelt sozusagen die durch Demokratie
legitimierte Mehrheit auf und das ist
ein klassisches rechtes Ideologie es ist
antidemokratisch und deswegen ist die
Aufmerksamkeit über darüber dass er in
seiner Jugend offensichtlich
im Besitz eines wirklich durch
komponierten
antisemitischen
Flugplatz gewesen ist von den weiteren
Dingen will ich jetzt nämlich zur
Kenntnis was sie recherchiert haben aber
das ist sozusagen das Faktum gewesen
das das kriegt dann natürlich eine
andere Bedeutung
formalen Demokratie gesprochen
ist vorbei ja aber er hat es anders
gemeint
den Gedanken anbringen dafür hat es
anders gemeint das ist das das ist der
Schlüsselwort ist ein Meister des
ungefähr ne ähm der ist in seiner
Sprache sehr unpräzise das bezieht sich
dann auf solche Formulierungen also die
Demokratie zurückholen heißt halt die
Mehrheit bei der nächsten Wahl erobern
für ihn ja also er will damit nicht die
Demokratie abschaffen aber die
Formulierung ist so unpräzise dass sie
den Verdacht zu